i've not
listened to this let's listen to it
together
and and see what it what it's about
[Music]
david jimmy from philly i'm sick and
[ __ ] tired
and listen to your [ __ ] about
unhinged trump supporters and this and
that
make
you can't withstand it david you got my
information [ __ ]
your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
from indiana flippy from indiana please
unmute you are on the air my friend
hi can you hear me yes i can hey david
it's me
um i just was wondering if you've ever
reconsidered making an only benz
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know
uh earning season is over and it's time
for you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh
five and a quarter inches
ladies and
leaders and gentlemen for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
stand back and stand by
let's please continue on person woman
man camera tv
that's amazing
a good memory because i'm cognitively
[Music]
there
[Music]
i'll tell you one thing boy there is a
kind of uh wwe
face i'll tell you one thing boy it's
almost like a poetry in a sense
i'll tell you one thing boy we need a
remix
i'll tell you one thing boy really
really gonna
go trump has got more money
than you'll ever have if it's a joke
it's like a three-year joke
we need a remix trump is more american
than you'll ever be what do you guys
think what do we need as a nickname for
that gentleman
[Music]
boy trump is more
man than you'll ever be i'll tell you
one thing
all right welcome everybody whoa
does anybody hear that or is that just
me
is there a song playing right now
[Music]
that's actually coming out of my vent
not a speaker
okay anyway um joe biden is going to
sign
into law a bill today
hold on what is the law it's a really
big deal but i just forgot what it is
um the president will be signing the the
corvid 19
hate crimes act into
law okay so that's today
um welcome everybody it's so great to
have you here and
we have so much to discuss i have
unbanned requests to
uh adjudicate and and just so much is
going on
um let me see where are we even from the
standpoint of
these streams uh there we are okay good
um okay let's get right i have so much
to talk about all right so let's get
right into it i do want to say
say thank you to obese luis for signing
up via twitch tangela irene for the
three months aj
for ow as well as green man
15 months for green man and 79
carlio all great people really
appreciate your support chakaseki
asks via super chat i heard a rumor joe
biden will announce that
doji coin will be replacing the us
dollar can you confirm that is not what
is being signed into law today i can
assure you that is not it uh and robert
says when does the greatest hits album
drop david yeah you know i still like
the idea of doing a spotify album with
those songs
that you heard before the stream started
when i asked for help publishing to
spotify all these people wrote to me
saying i work with an agency that can
get you published on spotify it's five
grand it's all this difference
i don't know guys i i i was thinking
there was just some simple way of
publishing these songs to spotify
but and i'm up for it but i you know it
can't become the biggest project
it's like mostly we're doing a political
show not music
people from california floridians what
are pac-man fans called do we have an
official name from the standpoint of
fanboys
we don't trolls are still saying you
didn't cover palestine absurd
yeah who cares uh any interest in
becoming a father
you know i would go i would go back to
what producer lewis once said
if i accidentally had a kid i'd probably
love the kid that's a famous phrase
etched in the minds of david pakman's
show
history um
i have one unbanned request to
adjudicate
this is a user oh i i do have my my uh
gavel today
this is a user named nightsabers
they've been a follower since december
8th on december 8th
they arrived and uh said
magga that's okay that's okay that's
allowed they weren't banned for that
then they said antifa was allowed to
riot just saying that was on january 6th
as the riots were going on this user
said antifa was allowed to riot i guess
in defense of what was going on that day
then they said water bottles were being
thrown by blm actually
um then
wow january 6th was a big big day for
them
then yesterday they showed up and they
said we're coming for
antifa this is the real revolution
cry liberals cry i hope it's civil war
because we have a list
david pakman is a hypocrite david pakman
is a soy boy real cuck
soy boys better get ready to duck and
cover
david pakman is paid by the ccp david
pakman is a traitor
then they were banned okay their unban
request is
poo poo please okay that's going to be a
deny
and perma and that one is done yeah
they're staying banned that's just
sorry but that is not happening that is
an abs that's an obvious you're making
my job too easy with that one
okay justin says if you don't have the
ban hammer it's not the same no i have
it i have
uh they're they're i mean that's just
it's a if i could double permaban them
that's what i would have done because
that's just such trash
all right i i don't i'm not even sure
really how to get into this as we stand
by for joe biden here but
there has been oh and we're getting very
close to this event now
there has just been a crazy situation
lately
where i don't even know how to introduce
this
because i don't know like who's mad at
who
um at one point everyone was mad at me
because of something related to israel
or palestine
then uh chris varsh
or also known to some just as vosh
said i'm a zionist and used the term
pejoratively even though the definition
of zionism that i i don't go by whatever
modern pejoratives are now used
zionism just means you think israel
should exist but in any case
varsh called me a zionist or a scientist
now i'm not even sure
then a streamer who
seems to be making a lot of money off of
me central corporation central committee
uh it's like mike from jersey or
something like that
he attacked vosh or me
or both and then stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell ii
attacked them
i wish i knew who was mad at who i i
just really don't know
um but here are like some clips i'm
trying to understand this as much as
other people seem to be
and you know i get the feeling that if i
was better at drama
like i could have started some kind of
beef beef with jimmy dore
months ago and it would have been like
great for my show i just am so busy
researching my stories and reading and
doing my gardening and stuff
that i don't know how to start the drama
with people
but it seems like if there's this many
people obsessed with me
there's some opportunity here like if i
was better at marketing maybe
anyway let's i'm just going to go
through these clips in no particular
order
here is destiny explains why vaush's
zionist accusation is weird even if
walked back okay like we're just going
to dive into these i don't even know
what's going on
captive i said you were like the writing
needs to stop we need a moment on
[ __ ] n words well
okay hold on i shouldn't call them n
words but what i really like that would
be like more comparable
it's just super super it's just super
[ __ ] weird
it's just like i'm giving you this for
life advice even for those that disagree
with me
you you do not call don't call
jewish people that don't live in israel
to call somebody in america a [ __ ]
zionist you are right there
like you are standing side by side with
a white supremacist that's like oh it's
beautiful i never thought we would come
together like this it's so beautiful
all right so there's one take and again
i'm just trying to understand what this
is even like
who so i'm from this one video i gather
steven is mad at varsh
that seems clear right okay next
there are so many tropes and i don't
even the thing is and i'm honest about
it by the way i'm the only person that
will be honest about it because i don't
instantly say people are racist or
anti-semitic or blah blah blah which i
don't think i've said for about i don't
know if he's anti-semitic
um but i mean like if i wanted to and
it's annoying too because like i do
treat these people with more [ __ ]
charitability than i would ever [ __ ]
get even though people constantly use me
neither like
a guy that was banned from twitch for
saying glass is real okay and then is
saying [ __ ] like
like pac-man is hiding his positions
like a sneaky jew i guess about his
zionism like what
like jesus [ __ ] like if any alt-righter
had made like this combination of
statements
your [ __ ] like nazi radar would be
exploding in your dashboard like oh nazi
nazi nazi that's absolutely
there's one million percent so steven
shot out of a cannon okay
then here is destiny
it says destiny talking about now
central corporation now do
destiny and corp are they together or
opposite let's see
i lived like david pakman try to take
her out with
disgusting [ __ ] innuendo this is
mike from jersey talking right and now
steven's talking about him is that
what's going on here
god if i was good at this stuff i would
be able to turn this into like a
50 000 subscribers but i don't even know
what to do with it as opposed to what
she actually believes and says
pretty amazing by the way
you know how uh people like david pakman
will do these [ __ ] little rap move
uh rats oh i mean i don't know
rat i don't know if that's going to be
commented on but
rat is i mean you know i don't want to
even say what it alludes to when you're
talking about a jewish person but
i don't know no one calls you know now
this is why he doesn't make videos
anymore
about about this issue chat what he
doesn't make videos about that anymore
that's why he's not making any videos
about the number one news story
what's in the [ __ ] world he's the
number one news story by the way for
this week
right nobody gives a [ __ ] about what was
happening in india and pakistan anymore
nobody really gives a [ __ ] oh my god i
found it thank you seems to give a [ __ ]
much about like the weaker stuff anymore
like we suffer from recentism so much
when it comes to stories and it's not
only that like you know the other thing
but yeah if they're talking about
israel-palestine of course i did
though i've done one 20-minute segment
on any topic in the last six months and
it was on the israeli-palestinian
conflict this week
can you imagine that but there is i
think another issue here which is
the let me see i'm going to speak so
clearly and i'm going to get really
close to the mic because i want to be
super understood and people can clip
this okay get the recorders ready
please criticism of the israeli
government
is not necessarily anti-semitic
everybody heard that right however
it is interesting that there are so many
people
who use thinly veiled
tropes about jews to talk about the ip
conflict
who never talk about what's going on
with the uyghurs
they never talk about what's going on in
eritrea
they have nothing to say about what
russia has done with ukraine
odessa etc they don't seem to have
any care about the haiti dominican
republic situation
like if the standard is the crises in
which the most
number of people are are dying
it's not the israeli-palestinian
conflict if
it's the conflict that has been
you know okay
all right um let's move on so i have one
more
oh this one we already did i think we
played this one already
work it would be more apt if i said you
like the writing needs to stop we need a
modem [ __ ] n words
okay yeah we played this one already all
right so there it is and again
i don't know it seems as though vosh and
mike
from uh god mike the central mike
are sort of together maybe and destiny's
against both of them
i don't know but a lot of people are
angry my my
uh my marketing sense tells me there's
something here that i could be making a
lot of money from
but um i don't know
i guess that's it can i play the vosh
clip
i don't i don't even have a vosh clip i
don't even know i i just i have no
the only clips i've seen are these um
yeah i don't know i don't know that's
sort of where i'm at right now
all right everybody thank you i do want
to say thanks to canned caviar for four
months subscribed on twitch
i want to say thanks to manny for three
months subscribed on twitch
uh thanks lurdon for the five months
it's me john b
is now 10 months in that crazy guy is
four months in i also want to say thank
you to b dog bdh 2002 gaming for the
three months of subs that's six people
um six plus five is eleven and i really
appreciate that
um and
i also yes i i do have a coupon code
going
uh better21 at joinpakman.com better1021
joinpakman.com i will um
be thanking every single person who
signs up at joinpackman.com
um
okay hold on here's a clip i've been
sent a clip this is the varsh clip
or vaash let's take a listen
this is my first time seeing any of this
stuff i'm not saying he's like some
hardcore netanyahu stan or anything
because i don't believe how could anyone
say that i think i i have 10 years of
public
opposition to benjamin netanyahu i've
called him disgusting
i'm glad varsh isn't saying that because
it would be insane to come away with
that impression
at all um i just um
no his opinion's different okay guys
wait
are there a hundred coins coins
maybe saying he's a zionist is a little
bit too strong of language
i would like to amend it if i could so
you know it's like this entire thing
about the zionist debate
ask me my opinion about policy
do i think a valid solution to the
israeli-palestinian conflict
is there's no more israel no i don't
i believe in a two-state solution i
believe in an israeli state and i
believe in a palestinian state
contiguous
palestinian state where everybody can
live in peace you lift the blockade
right so it's a debate without defining
terms that's the crazy thing it seems
it seems wild to me to to be like oh
uh he's a zionist no he's not yes he is
well maybe zionist was too far hold on a
second wait what
whoa whoa what are we talking about here
if we're talking about is is no more
israel
the the definition of what is a zionist
or are you defining it some other way
does zionism mean you support likud
does zionism mean you support netanyahu
or whatever okay let's listen to a
little more
um i would say
how do i say this
okay
i i think he plays enlightened centrist
on it a little bit more than i'm
comfortable with
does that make i i invented enlightened
centrist
i play enlightens and i invented the
concept
and i believe i applied it to dave rubin
into tim poole
right what
okay i'm you know why i can't do the
drama streaming because i'm so bored by
this
this is so boring makes sense
a little bit more charitable to israel
than i think is comfortable
a little bit less charitable to um
palestine
okay all right there's vosh um
anyway i don't know
big thank you to lorraine you know what
really makes me happy
thanking people uh lorraine gilb
just signed up at joinpacman.com
lorraine
love you all right new member number 12
today
very much appreciate that let's get to
some super chats are there 100 coins
though i don't know
pair says what about ism i'm
disappointed david no no no no no pair
that is a rhetorical crutch on which
some non-thinking people
rest their full weight which is when i
say
i'm interested in why
there are people who only care
tweet and activate around the
israeli-palestinian conflict
and not any of the other six things i
mentioned
it's not what about ism it's not saying
any one of the conflicts doesn't matter
it's you have no direct connection to
any of these countries
so why are you choosing only one of
these instead of the other six
it's it's not it's it's not what about
ism would be saying
don't worry about this because of this
other thing
that's not what i'm saying what i'm
saying is for those who are just
interested in perpetuating anti-semitic
tropes
talking only about the
israeli-palestinian conflict is
convenient
because you can't do anti-semitic tropes
on what's going on in eritrea
on ukraine russia
on any of these other things so it's not
what about ism
it's not what about what about ism would
be saying no one should care about the
israeli-palestinian conflict and instead
they should only care about the uyghurs
or whatever else the kid or myanmar
or saudi arabia and yemen or whatever
the case may be and by the way
for the people who say the reason
israeli-palestinian conflict is
completely different than all of those
is because of
american funding of israel saudi arabia
yemen guys come on
there's what two to three percent as
much stuff about that
so all of these issues are important is
the point
all of these issues are important is the
point all of these issues are important
is the point and so when you find people
who can't give a logically valid reason
why they don't talk about any of the
others it's something to explore
okay let's move on did i see the biden
speech yesterday
uh yes we we uh
covered it yeah i loved it it was great
um varsh did call you a scientist it was
just a misunderstanding oh okay
so it was scientist not zionist i got
that
um
[Music]
deepak omni pilled by the way one of the
most
entertaining thing i really have to tell
you one of the most entertaining things
for me
um when i uh get an alert
uh a google alert that there are clips
of mine
posted to the stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell ii
subreddit um reading the comments
on my clips on the destiny subreddit
i find absolutely uh uh hilarious i
don't know why
um david love the show and love what you
do much love from massachusetts thanks
koba
blake feely says mike from pa wants to
have a civil conversation with you
okay you think is that it has anything
to do with you not supporting the
charity because you found out that it is
allegedly
funneling money to terrorists do i think
what has something to do with that
see the other ones in reports then all
reporters
is wallist watist
man i don't know what pair is talking
about i wouldn't take the vooch clips
too seriously he stayed up for 24 hours
and is probably
confused okay uh
all right i want to say thank you to
lynn
siegel lynn just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
lin paid full price not even using a
coupon code just being safe doesn't want
to get arrested for those illegal coupon
codes
lynn thank you i really appreciate that
i also want to say thanks to libra girl
as well as
cena mcmillan nate the younger just
signed up via twitch and says i subbed
because you invented enlightened
centrism
based also dj captainblee
out of my window zk4 thank you baby
jesus for my hot wife
retox have all signed up that's one two
three four
five six seven eight also thanks to
political puppy for the 17 months that's
nine
putting us at 22 um
just just a very serious reminder
if you have amazon prime you have five
dollars available to you every month
that you can give to a streamer of your
choice via twitch prime
it doesn't have to be me but give it to
someone if you don't
you're leaving the money in jeff bezos
pocket
if you have amazon prime right now you
can take five bucks out of bezos pocket
and give it to me or whoever else
if you like whoever okay just make sure
you're using it
and remember that it does not renew
automatically does not run you
automatically okay
um all right other super chats from the
coast guard
fan from lucerne switzerland wow i love
that i may be in switzerland this um
this summer actually i have a wedding to
go to in italy which hopefully happens
i will be in spain beforehand and the
in-between is a question mark
it may be it may be zurich in fact
i actually spent over the last two days
i think i've spent about
seven hours holding i do other work
while i'm holding
with american airlines and iberian
airlines i had all these really powerful
flight credits with american from
cancelled pandemic trips
so because iberian airlines code shares
with american
i had this five head big brain seven
head idea
that i would use my credits to book
iberian airlines flights
through american airlines because the
iberian airline flights are the most
convenient for the part of spain that
i'm going to
so um i booked it all and it was great
but then i wanted seats and so american
says because these are iberian airlines
flights you've got to call iberian
airlines
that it took me three hours to learn
that and then i call iberian airlines
and after two hours holding they
say this was purchased through american
airlines we
sir we can't assign new seats the
conversation was actually in spanish
they said senor
they were actually calling me senior
david
we can't assign you seats you have to
call american airlines and i said i
do you guys can i conference you guys
together
so you could maybe figure out how i can
get seats um
insane waste of time but ultimately i
have the ticket i have
no seat that's where we are right now
okay
astro ascension tarot
says a two-state solution is best i'm
center-left
john says i've been watching your
channel for years thanks for the honest
content
um pair says efco
no fcos i love your show keeping you on
your toes
all right have you read the tyranny of
merit by michael sandel i did not i have
not read it
deepak loved the content i think you
just missed pcrf a little too quickly if
you dig into the connections to hamas
they seem like a stretch
that may be you know for international
relief
i love um i love the red cross
that's my default because i i don't feel
like there's any question mark
um yeah i don't even have anything else
to say about that
will right-wing terrorism increase due
to big lie in future elections
sadly yes sadly yes
thanks for turning me on to the toontoon
channel david how is it not more popular
the production value is out of this
world yeah let's check in on toontoon
youtube
here it is um toontoon had upper
management written all over him
so let's just look at some of these
clips
so i uh proposed that people
um let's see even where they're what's
going on copy link address
a couple months ago i said to people hey
you guys should really sign up for the
subscribe to this channel because it's
it's great
um it's a guy i know and he does thai
cooking
and look at the effect this is the
pacman effect
on the toontoon channel uh where was
this
wait how can i figure this out weekly
weekly user summary detailed statistics
i would like to go by month see look at
this this was when i promoted the
channel right here
um and it was this massive bump right
here it went from oh wait no it was even
before that anyway he had 300
subscribers and then now he's at 6 000.
the channel's still doing great there's
some of the top cooking videos i believe
on uh on youtube right now beautifully
filmed perfectly executed
and uh i was thinking it might be cool
if i did a crossover
with the toontoon channel where i
learned to cook some of these dishes
i think that would be interesting i
don't know maybe that would go on the
forthcoming second youtube channel
someday but a lot of different ideas
that we're working with
alvaro says greetings from sunny and
rainy costa rica i would love
i almost went to costa rica and then the
pandemic
and then the pandemic tragic but i hope
to get there soon
um legionary dragon says have you heard
about the us and philippine
navies working together and pushing out
chinese boats
off wit sun reef last month i did not
hear about that
can we meet i need to talk english for a
school test
i'm busy today joel i apologize
tyler says most memorial day subs will
be dropped in a month
no no no no no david
senor can you get good pulpo where you
are
pulpo lagasega is one of my faves oh
yeah i'm gonna be
in galicia in august i will be
in santiago de compostela and other
related places
i will be at the central market and i
will be having the octopus there is no
doubt about it
i've had that before it is one of the
best octopi i've had let's see if i can
even find a video
octopus
[Music]
um
i believe that it is this
yeah that's that's great that's a great
dish
yep this is where it is this is where
i'll be
today we are going to prepare octopus
alfeira right anyway it's just octopus
with paprika and sweet paprika yeah
first step
we are going to cut the octopus
into slices i love octopus that's just
my favorite basically
we're going to place it in a
nicer way
look at that yeah i know that's a great
dish
once we place all the octopus let's drop
some olive oil
vanish olive oil ideally
it has a beautiful color absolutely
okay and we will it's funny when people
are like
this looks too simple to possibly be any
good but it's like no no no that's
that's what makes it so good
you know you don't need uh crispy fried
onions
deep fried and dropped on top of it and
then a white sauce and that type of
stuff
this is cooked yeah this is good uh
sweet paprika
in more quantity than the spicy paprika
for the spicy paprika we need to add
just
a little bit
nothing like this enough and
with
a bit of spicy
the spicy is the best that's great stuff
yeah so anyway
i will be in galicia this summer spain
opening really really strongly
and looking forward to being there thank
you to techolote for four months
subscribed on twitch
lucas orion welcome for the first time
fresh cut
grass just signed up odw
is now in for seven months also thanks
to ali oops and the dark unicorn
cm herox and nathan's
scotto trauma and kami kavis
felden thatcher and the apple bit
that's 12. uh thank you very much
12 and 22 is 34. i appreciate that
let's do a little something extra today
only
website memberships get ready for this
they count triple
three times one all right join
pacman.com memberships today only count
triple and if we get to a hundred the
phones are going wide open and i mean
wide open other super chats trump is
furious because they think he got more
votes but they are against ending
electoral college
are they against it or not complete
hypocrisy
one of the many inconsistencies of
course one of the many inconsistencies
uh you read over my comment earlier
david oh i'm sorry let's see
you can put your music in spotify for
free david what are you on about they're
probably scamming you well i've not paid
anybody anything so nobody has scammed
me but it's possible someone is
attempting to scam
scam me that's perfectly possible pepe
says tacos or burritos
i used to be bigger on burritos lately i
am more
into uh into tacos
much more into the tacos lately owen
says what are you growing this summer in
the garden i
i've played the video twice um i guess i
could pull it up real quick
here's what i'm growing in my garden
right now
um
let's see here
this is the garden
and we'll do playback speed slower
so we've got your uh you've got your
swiss charge we'll just do a quick tour
through it we're not going to do it like
you know yesterday a jalapeno pepper
there that's a hollow jalapeno pepper
plant
uh beautiful jalapenos
that is my um gourmet purple lettuce
it starts there's actually i realized
there's two kinds there's these big
purple leaves on the left and then kind
of like a purplish green leaf on the
right it's really two plants i didn't
even realize it
my perennial mint back on its own
looking really strong
um this is already five days old so it's
like crazy what's going on
these are chocolate tomatoes they don't
taste like chocolate but they're just
kind of brownish red
some italian basil there's my flat leaf
parsley
my yellow sun sugar tomatoes
and then a little more italian basil
genovese basil as some people refer to
it
and then these these tomatoes are going
to be great yellow cherry hybrids
it's a beautiful hybrid here's another
tomato plant the one that's already
biggest
and um
[Music]
yeah that's going to be great stuff a
little bit of a weed there which i pull
look at that strong pole just right out
by the roots everything's out
then we've got our cukes this is a lemon
cucumber they grow they're round and
yellow it's a round yellow cucumber it's
very interesting
here are my sugar snap peas and i've got
a bunch of different plants
throwing shoots everywhere
yeah this is my greek oregano i know
some people are like we've seen this
every day but somebody asked that's my
greek oregano came back on its own it's
full full bush this is a yellow banana
pepper
or banana pepper i guess they're kind of
greenish yellow
another tomato this is an orange tomato
i believe
or red now i don't remember
and then that's another type of pepper
i've got my italian oregano look at that
i made a pizza yesterday
using a pesto i made from that oregano
english thyme
cilantro or coriander as some people
call it
japanese eggplant two japanese eggplant
plants
and my second year strawberry bush which
is going to be very productive i can
already tell i got six strawberries out
of it last year
there's 30 there must be 30 seeds on it
already
look at that strawberry
so that's it okay that's what we've got
today from the garden i'll do an update
soon because there are
major developments already it's grown
quite a bit in fact since i even filmed
that
coriander and cilantro are yeah so
here's the thing
coriander is the seed in the united
states we call cilantro the leaf that
you use like on
on tacos and then the coriander
is like an er it's a spice it's a seed
that you can toast and grind up
in the uk i believe in india maybe in
some other countries
they just refer to cilantro as coriander
but yeah it's the same thing it's the
same thing
michelle says you skipped my earlier
comment oh i'm sorry michelle let me see
we're pack heads all right thank you
michelle
packheads is certainly an idea
um david sir my wife authorized me to
send you five dollars to find out what
kind of soil you use for your potted
vegetables it's different
soils different soils over time i keep
just
mixing in new soil and all of the dead
plants from the previous year
and i've gotten a couple of different
types of soil a bunch of different
things not i couldn't
list them though i don't know what
they're called frankie says ever thought
of living in california
uh yes i may be living there right now
in fact
watched your content since dnc 2012. you
helped me understand politics and i've
worked four campaigns since as an
organizer and a field director nice
dwayne glad you got involved
that's fantastic mike says republicans
sign abortion bill in texas do you think
this is because of this event for biden
um no and we covered that on today's
bonus show actually
we covered that story on the bonus show
i encourage you to check it out
daniel says i knew a chiropractor who
treated ballpark vendors was cracking
backs for cracker jacks
nice nicely done
james says did you see the 60 minute ufo
video what are your thoughts
yeah my my takeaways are it's probably
some kind of foreign countries
i i think it's a combination so i go
with the most likely explanation
and for me the most likely explanation
is that some of the observations that
are made
are not entirely accurate when they say
it was moving
at x speed or something like that
that may not be completely accurate uh
and it seems to me
that the most likely explanation is this
is some kind of foreign surveillance
thing
or even something so secret that even
the people who are flying around
for the u.s navy and air force just
don't know what it is they may not even
be cleared
i don't know what do i know
it's oxfam's razor exactly desiree
de long just signed up at
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
now watch this this is something special
website memberships count triple today
so desiree gets us number 35
36 and 37.
on the other hand m ballant
g watts johnny x
have all signed up on twitch that's
three people
and that also counts as three because
you've got our
your sort of triple your money thing
tyler says from the standpoint of
medical how did you react to your second
dose
uh arm pain fever
headache flu-like neck pain
in bed for about a day and then i was
immune
so it was a great thing frumpus
says record break this is the biggest
may 20th 2021 news and politics stream
hosted by a left-handed argentinian jew
with u.s citizenship i think that that's
correct
i think that it's a privilege to be
hosting it veggies are looking good do
you use any sort of chemical additives
no how are your npk levels i have no
idea
i've never tested it my girlfriend is a
huge fan of the garden grows excellent
yeah
so this is something very special but
next week i got moderna by the way for
people asking next week
we may have a big time gardening youtube
channel that will do a reaction to my
garden
and i'm really looking forward to that
honestly i'm looking forward to it more
than
most stuff uh on on youtube
anti-matter says you need to triple your
output of plants you're producing covet
and poorly planned farming areas have
devastated our supply lines
all right will do ryan says if you
haven't read about grafting plants you
can get a plant to grow multiple types
of fruit many are trees but it's not
exclusive to this yeah i've looked at
some of the grafting stuff it's
interesting
very interesting um and i would be uh
i would be open to looking at more of it
okay let me pull up a couple of other
things that i wanted to look at
oh so yesterday i i did like a rant
about cancel culture and um joe rogan's
comments and i got a bunch of emails
from people saying they loved it and a
bunch of emails from people saying it
made no sense whatsoever and i should
never do that again
so i thought i would just look back at
it um
here it is let's just take a listen this
is me yesterday i want to see if i think
it made sense or not
a lot of people that are taking
advantage
of this weirdness in our culture and
then that becomes
their thing their thing is calling
people out for their privilege calling
people out
okay so i think joe rogan goes way too
far here
and th this this issue of you know
wokeness and uh
um who gets to speak and all this
different stuff
it it's being dramatically overblown
so here's my take on it okay um
in general critical let's let me see i
want to make
i want to make this like a seven head
take i don't want to just kind of like
throw out some stuff here i really want
to like address this
because this is a real issue and i think
there's an important conversation here
let me see if i can gather my thoughts
um a lot of these modern yeah i sort of
like blacked out during this rant so i'm
reviewing it it's almost like i'm seeing
it for the first time
critical theories um that include
critical race theory
and uh others sort of were
birthed by um
foucault uh post-modernism
um and they focus for my
take from for my for my taste and from
from my perspective
uh too much on all narrative
is valid and uh
language okay now the
is the word fucoian is that a word can
someone just
quickly uh we decided it is check me on
that
is that the term fucoian
dear god no one knows it is now okay
people know what i mean the fucoian
um a postmodernist idea
was actually a really great thing
for the analysis of literature of
literature okay the problem
that i have is that when applied
to a lot of other areas
whether it's the economy whether it's
race whether it's i don't know guys
making a lot of sense
it essentially makes it impossible
for us to say hey you know what not all
ideas are valid
not every narrative deserves an equal
seat at the table
etc and this really goes both ways
because the right loves to critique the
left
along the lines of every narrative is
equally valid and and all this other
stuff
um by saying look by the left's
philosophy on this um
any this is pretty good i'm liking this
actually the
understanding about economic struggles
is equally valid and we can't say that
just doesn't make any sense that's not
based on fact
we don't need to really consider that
okay i heard it it makes no sense
we're eliminating that from the
discussion and
what you get when you're driving
a principle is that all narratives are
equally valid
and especially narratives attached to
certain language or certain identity are
more valid
that is a problem that is a problem and
this is not me going anti-woke or or
anything
the the point is that the foucault
ian post-modernist
ideas which did a lot of great things
for analysis of literature
i don't think are serving us
particularly well in some of these
other areas i'm liking it guys i'm not
going to watch the entire thing but
that's making a lot of sense to me i
have to tell you so tomorrow maybe we'll
review
me reviewing that from yesterday but i
think that that's kind of interesting i
don't know what to tell you
tell me if i'm wrong i want to say thank
you to rachel
owery kevin
gouldy and marley price
all three of whom just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
website memberships count 3x today 3
times 3 is
9 9 plus 40 0 plus 9 is 9 and
4 is 49. also big thank you to
j.m stanek in shaw music
jon snow awakens gemini
boilermaker don norn
all of whom just signed up via twitch
that's six putting us at 55.
appreciate that very much okay other
super chats coming in let me see what
we've got here
a rest in peace cantaro muira
i apologize but i don't know who that is
let me see who that is
japanese manga artist best known for
berserk
okay yes rest in peace died uh
two weeks ago thanks for letting us know
what are your thoughts on cinema and
mansion you'd have to be a little more
specific than that
but we spoke about them a little bit on
yesterday's show
monoxide has retracted a message
frankie delgado says i'm 25 wasn't going
to vaccinate but your videos made it
clear
mom and i took jnj feel good nicely done
frankie
put at least two vaccinations in my name
please uh if anybody's keeping a ledger
david the ufo videos were debunked
thunderfoot gives a good debunking the
lens shutter shape can make any shape
math shows the tic tac is a bird oh okay
yeah
i don't know joe was going to speak
about alzheimer's today but he forgot ah
that's lame i don't know that's not even
if that counts as comedy right now then
we're in trouble
we're in real trouble uh papa
okay yeah we are standing by for joe
biden now someone told me
jen saki is still going with her press
briefing that can't possibly be true can
it
no it ended at least a half hour ago let
me see here
no yeah this is this is the next event
there are the channels live
they should be starting any moment
they're about 20 20 minutes late right
now
so it should be it should be starting uh
quite soon
uh let me get to a couple of voicemails
um
let me see here got a couple from the
eggman
um about masking in upstate new york
let's take a listen
hi dave and pat i am over two weeks
since my second
vaccination i went shopping in wegmans
yesterday
with no mask on because my state lifted
these mask requirements
it felt great i'm not going to get
covered other people without masks are
either vaccinated or they don't care and
they have or and they weren't
and they just don't follow rules so i
think people that are already vaccinated
to just stop wearing masks and we should
move on with this
um i did it to be safe i didn't took a
virtue signal and now that i'm safe i'm
not wearing it
so i don't see any reason for people to
wear masks do you think
some people that are all vaccinated
still wear masks
just a virtue signal even though they're
safe and they just want to
keep showing people you should wear them
yeah shalom brother
yeah yeah no i've seen a lot of people
post on facebook like i don't think i
even need a mask anymore i'm fully
vaccinated
i'm going to wear it so people don't
think i'm a republican um
so there's definitely people doing that
i'm not doing that when the cdc said no
more outdoor masks needed
i haven't worn it outdoors since unless
i'm like waiting in line you know at a
grocery store that says please wear your
mask in line
um and places that require the mask
indoors i'm wearing i'm just following
cdc guidelines state guidelines
and uh the guidelines of businesses it's
that simple for me okay
um here's an oh the eggman also had
another uh
call let's listen hi dave i'm a proud
new yorker and i just want to tell you
andrew giuliani will never win anything
in new york no public office not
governor not
dog catcher nothing his father's head
melted
and he farted on live tv
he is the laughing stock of new york
state right really
nobody is voting for this guy no worries
in new york state
what did he say his face melted and he
farted that's stupid
before kovid hit in the very beginning i
was one of the first people to wear a
mask at work and i got dirty looks and
then it became mandatory
this week i stopped wearing my mask
because i'm well over two weeks double
vaccinated
i got more dirty looks and then two days
later no more masks
mandatory where i work i am ahead of the
curve
i've beaten this covered crap america
has beaten it
people that are double vaccinated should
not wear masks
anymore anywhere that's the whole point
of this i'm not
a virtue signaling by wearing a mask i'm
just being safe and now that i'm safe
i'm done we should all stop wearing them
you should stop wearing a mask
everywhere now david because you're
double facts
well i'm following state law if state
law is still
x then i'm going to do x um but
yeah i mean uh you know it's it's all
happening
it's all happening we have not yet
beaten covid but we are well on our way
uh by the way the uh
the rudy farting thing i've almost
forgotten about it i want to review that
rudy giuliani
fart a lot of the stuff that happened
before joe biden was president
it almost feels not real the answer that
i gave you is they didn't bother to
interview a
single witness just like you they don't
want to know the truth it's still just
as funny
it really is
um hi mr giuliani representative
i'm just i'm just hoping to get an
answer to the other questions about
you know mr barr and others who have
disproportionately i gave you the answer
point of order the answer that i gave
you is they didn't bother to interview a
single
witness just like you they don't want to
know the team very very freedom
yeah that that was a wild
that was a wild time i mean it's just
crazy this is almost as
as good as you all know my favorite
clips
where is my favorite trump clip hold on
trump audio
engineer oh i can't find it
hold on let's see if i can find it here
trump struggling with the audio is
basically the best
um
so let's see hold on trump audio
engineer trump audio
feedback 2020
i don't even remember when it was
damn now i can't find it that's too bad
was it if i search for trump feedback
will it come up
no man that's really too bad and i know
that i have them
somewhere in my wiki my internal wiki
that's too bad democratic audio engineer
yeah democratic audio engineer
no it's not coming up that's really too
bad those are some of my favorite clips
um i know i i'm like searching my own
internal database i just don't know what
to find
what what to search for trump um
microphone feedback
no don't pay that guy
yeah exactly trump
don't don't pay that guy
yeah it's oh here it is hold on oh wait
no that's not it that's trump talking
about not paying black people
um trump microphone feedback
oh here it like they is
heard for a long time i'm fighting for
school choice
right right good choice big deal
safe neighborhoods hispanic-owned small
businesses we have great great small
business people here i know some of them
i've helped some of them
and aren't incredible oh these people
don't know what the hell they're doing
that's the best let me recover my ears
for one second
[Applause]
whoever did this microphone don't pay
him
right you know i have a reputation for
not paying
and it's a false reputation when
somebody does a lousy job
like a microphone that's no good or like
teleprompters that fly with the wind
i say don't pay him but we love our
incredible hispanic american members of
law enforcement yeah man that is just
the best
by the vice president of the united
states all right here we go
big big day
no mask oh my god fox news is gonna lose
their minds
oh is anybody wearing it looks like
nobody's wearing masks wow
[Applause]
wow
all righty then
[Laughter]
good afternoon by the way the step that
kamala stands on when she's
i love it for some reason when she steps
up
to all of the leaders here thank you
thank you to the members of our united
states congress
on both sides of the aisle who helped
pass
the covid 19 hate crimes act
right thank you
and a special thanks to senator maisie
hirono
[Applause]
and congresswoman grace maine
for leading this incredible effort and i
know you did not do it alone
and there are many more i could name a
couple of whom i will
among them senator tammy duckworth
[Applause]
senator richard blumenthal
senator jerry moran
[Applause]
congresswoman judy chu
congressman don beyer
[Applause]
and congressman fred upton
republicans are furious that they're not
wearing masks now which is what they
wanted
history will remember this day
and this moment when our nation took
action to combat hate
thank you all around this time
last year when i was in the senate
senator hirono and senator duckworth and
i
introduced a resolution in the united
states senate
condemning the rise of anti-asian
sentiment in our country
at that time more than 1 thousand one
hundred
anti-asian hate incidents had been
reported
since the start of the pandemic today
that number is more than six thousand
six hundred
and i'm talking about incidents where
businesses
are being vandalized in our biggest
cities and in our smallest towns
i'm talking about a 61 year old man
getting kicked in the head
two elderly women being stabbed while
waiting for the bus
eight people in atlanta getting shot on
a tuesday night
this violence it did not come from
nowhere
and none of it is new in my life
my lived experience i have seen how hate
can pervade our communities i have
served
in the justice system in the legislative
branch
and in the executive branch i have seen
how hate can impede our progress
and i have seen how people
uniting against hate can strengthen our
country
those here today are united
this bill brings us one step closer
to stopping hate not only for asian
americans but for all americans
it will expedite the justice
department's review of hate crimes
every type of hate crime it will
designate an official
at the department to oversee the effort
and it will expand efforts to make the
reporting of hate crimes
more accessible at the local and state
levels
but after the president signs this bill
today right
our work will not be done here is the
truth racism exists in america
xenophobia exists in america fox news
maldives anti-semitism
islamophobia homophobia transphobia
it all exists uh-oh and so the work
to address injustice that's
controversial these days
among some remains the work ahead
my fellow americans it is my great honor
to mention and to say to you what you
already know
we have a president of the united states
in one joe biden who doesn't call it the
china virus committed
to this work he is determined
to i will quote from him give hate
no safe harbor and
i'll tell you firsthand i've seen what
you know
his actions match his powerful words
wow it is my great honor to introduce
the president of the united states
joe biden usually someone runs over and
pulls the step stool
it might be this guy let's see it's such
a smooth move there he goes and he pulls
the stool i don't know why i find that
so endearing
i love that
[Applause]
thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you
susan progress is possible
we're moving good afternoon everyone
[Music]
i said from the beginning of my uh
campaign madam speaker that uh
the campaign for president throughout
and you would call me and tell me keep
it up
was about bringing people together about
uniting the country
we need you to rent we need to unite
as one people one nation one america
and that was the thing i was most often
criticized about saying how can unite
the country
we must unite the country i said it my
kickoff speech in philadelphia
i said it again when i spoke at
gettysburg
and i emphasized it in my inaugural
address
just one brief inter interruption one of
the things that's great about these
events
is right wingers are just desperate to
stop joe biden from doing anything and
to make up all these fake scandals
and he's just quietly doing stuff and
signing stuff into law doing covet
stimulus moving forward on this moving
forward on that
the masks have come off at a certain
point because we're we're moving forward
and they're just so
furious that he's just doing things and
ignoring them
and i love it racism the ugly poison
that has long haunted and plagued our
nation
today i can say that because of all of
you many of you sitting right in front
of me
you've taken that first step this
important step
i'd like to thank the congress and the
members who are here today democrats and
republicans
who came together to get the covet 19
hate crimes act
on my desk well on a desk i'm about to
sign on
but i want to thank the majority leader
schumer
and i want to thank speaker pelosi for
your leadership
i also want to thank our the leader from
the state of kentucky for letting it go
forward
it's important it's important most of
all
amazing senator
i called you maisy i apologize mazie
i called chuck chuck anyway yeah
senator hirano senator tammy duckworth
who
helped deliver this 94 to one vote
when you get involved tammy you don't
screw around you're just
94 to 1. state representative
man judy chu who helped deliver a 600
and should be 364 to 62 vote in the
house of representatives
that's incredible i also want to thank
as i said
republican members in congress was josh
hawley the one guy who voted against
senator collins i also want to thank the
uh
as i said to tell and to all to all
of the folks all the people here today
who are involved and those of you
whether you're
in the congress or not supporting this
effort i say thank you thank you thank
you
it was cruiser holly we simply haven't
seen this kind of bipartisanship
for much too long this isn't a senator
guys
you're showing our that our democracy
can work and deliver for the american
people
just days after the mass shooting in
atlanta
area the vice president harris and i we
went down to atlanta to meet with asian
americans
and the community across georgia it was
a raw
and emotional visit we had we heard
about their pain their fear
anger and all that existed in the
community and the feelings were
about those feelings that they felt
invisible
not seen we heard how too many asian
americans have been
waking up each morning this past year
genuinely
genuinely fearing for their safety just
opening the door and walking down the
street
and safety for their loved ones the moms
and dads when they let their kids out
the door to go to school
or worried attacked blamed
scapegoated harassed during this
pandemic
living in fear for their lives as i said
just walking
down the street grandparents afraid to
leave their homes even to get vaccinated
for fear of being attacked small
business owners targeted and gunned down
students worried about two things covet
19
and being bullied documented incidents
of hate against asian americans has seen
a shocking spike as the vice president
has outlined at the front of which her
comments
let alone let alone the ones that have
never been reported
gut-wrenching attacks on some of the
most vulnerable people in our nation the
elderly low-wage workers women
brutally attacked simply by walking
outside or waiting for a bus
asian-american women suffer twice as
many incidents as harassment
and violence as asian-american men
the conversation we had in atlanta is
one we're hearing all across the country
that all of this hate hides in plain
sight
it hides in plain sight and too often
it is met with silence silenced by the
media
silenced by our politics and silenced by
our history
for centuries asian americans native
hawaiians pacific islanders diverse and
vibrant communities
have helped build this nation only to be
often stepped over
forgotten or ignored
you know lived here for generations
but still considered by some the other
the other it's wrong
it's simply to use the phrase it's
simply un-american
my message to all of those of you are
hurting is we see you
and the congress has said we see you
and we are committed to stop the hatred
and the bias
my first week in office i signed a
presidential memorandum
directing federal agencies all of them
to combat the resurgence of xenophobia
not just one
every agency attorney general garland
deputy attorney general lisa monaco
associate attorney
general gupta are all here today
the department of justice is
strengthening his partnership with the
community to prevent these crimes
in addition to its other work to take on
violent extremism
and domestic terrorism and with the new
law
this new law the department of justice
and our entire administration is going
to step
up right now this is a critical problem
of hate crimes being under reported
it stems from two challenges first
there's lack of resources and training
for state and local law enforcement to
accurately identify and report
hate crimes to the fbi secondly
for more people in communities of color
there are language and cultural barriers
in how to communicate what's happening
to them
this law is going to make a difference
for example the department of justice
will issue clear guidance for state city
and tribal and law enforcement agencies
on how to establish online reporting of
hate crimes
it will work with the department of
health and human services to raise
public awareness of covet 19 hate crimes
that occurred
during the pandemic will also be a
devoted official
at the department of justice whose sole
job
is to expedite the review of hate crime
reports
and thanks to two families here today
we'll all help state
and local governments ensure hate crime
information is more accessible to the
public
the family of heather heyer a civil
rights activist whose life was taken
standing up to nazis marching from the
shadows of
vengeance in charlottesville and the
family of collide jabra
a proud son of a family who's immigrated
from lebanon
in search of new beginnings was gunned
down in front of their home
here in america the united states of
america
by a neighbor fueled by hate clete and
heather were murdered
on the same day one year apart
instead of sharing the dreams they had
for their children
both families share profound grief and
they've shown incredible courage
to turn their pain into purpose i hope
you'll not be offended but
ask both families to please stand
wow
i want to thank you
i want to thank you for being here
because i know it's hard
no matter how celebratory it is it's a
lost being changed
when you have to show up at something
memorializing your family
it's like you got the news 10 seconds
ago
[Music]
it's the hardest thing to do
i know from experience it takes enormous
courage
but i hope i hope that every day that's
passed
the memory showing daughter
brings a smile to your lips before it
brings a tear to your eye
because i promise you a lot of people
understand have gone through similar
things
it's hard so i really mean when i say
thank you
thank you for being here it takes a lot
of courage
shouldn't he be insulting someone i
don't know
because of you the amendment named in
honor of khalid and heather
is now law to make sure that hate crimes
are more accurately counted and reported
and hopefully leading to a continued
focus on
ending these crimes it will provide
resources to create specialized hate
crimes units
that will also help states create
hotlines for hate crimes at state and
local levels
that will be accessible for people with
limited english proficiency
and provides resources for training for
state and local law enforcement
to identify investigate and report these
heinous crimes
but of all the good the law can do
we have to change our hearts
we have to change the hearts of the
american people
hate can't i mean this is from the
bottom of my heart
hate can be given no safe harbor in
america
i mean it no safe harbor it can't be
dismissed
like well that's just what happens
my sister valerie and i talk about it
all the time
you've got to speak up speak up and
speak out
it's on all of us all of us together
to make it stop my message is
to all of those who think this doesn't
matter to them or this is not a problem
look around look in the mirror
look in the area
every one of us are lessened
every one of us are lessened and we're
all hurt
by this hate and as a way of seeping
sort of through the cracks in the
communities and children who
in fact wouldn't have crossed their mind
words have consequences the senator
knows
he preaches it he understands it
consequences but silence
is complicity silence is complicity
and we cannot be complicit we have to
speak
out we have to act that's what you've
done
and i can't thank you enough
i'm proud today i'm proud today
of the united states i'm proud today
of our political system the united
states congress i'm proud today
that democrats and republicans have
stood up together
to say something
let me close with this wow
grief as we all know is universal
but so is hope so is love
sounds corny but it really is it really
is
and hope and love can be contagious
we're the united states of america right
we're good and decent people
we're unique among all nations and that
we are uniquely a product
of a document not an ethnicity
not a religion not a geography
of a document and think about this i'm
being literal
uniquely a product with document that
says we hold these truths to be
self-evident
that all men and women are created equal
endowed by their creator with certain
inalienable rights
including life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
every time we're silent gonna have to
turn it down
every time we let hate flourish
we make a lie of who we are as a nation
i mean it literally
we cannot let the very foundation
of this country continue to be eaten
away
like it has been in other moments in our
history and happening again
i looked at this law that you all passed
as maybe the first
break the first significant break
in a moment in our history that has to
be turned around not democrat
has to be turned around as a consequence
we should do what is required by the
obligations of this democracy
by our faith in god and our faith in
each other
to do justice to love mercy
to walk humbly and as fellow human
beings and fellow americans
remember we're unique in all of history
as a nation
this is the united states of america for
god's sake
and god bless you all particularly those
who push this through
and continue to push it now i'm going to
sign this bill
which is a great honor
i don't know who's calling but tell them
we're busy
oh man i was going to say unless it was
my sister but she's here
so i'd like to invite to the stage
senator hirano senator duckworth
congresswoman grace congresswoman judy
chu
congresswoman don beyer senator richard
blumenthal
and let's sign this thing senator moran
but i don't think he could be here today
actually he should have you i should put
the table down the middle of all of you
and sign it down there i hope it's that
tiny desk
everybody's vaccinated masks are off
shouldn't they be sharpies yeah
he's not holding it up even
[Music]
[Applause]
things are being done can't say things
aren't being done
[Music]
all right thank you thank you
i've heard this says before as i walk
down my grandpa's house every time he
said joe and keep the faith
my grandmother didn't know joey spread
it
see his little stories he tells are
totally authentic he's telling them in
private you know
not literally private but off mike
anyway
we're going back to handshaking
questions being yelled from the back
please remain seated while the president
and the vice president department thank
you
god to scream
did someone just tell merrick garland
he's the second best attorney general i
think i heard that
question from oan um
about hunter's laptop coming in all
right well listen
very good uh an anti-hate bill was
signed that's a great thing
i had one other thing which i forgot to
go over with you guys before but it's
really funny
so earlier in the stream we played all
these clips of
you know destiny talking about vosh
talking about me talking about va you
know this whole entire thing
last night when i was just looking at uh
twitch
and youtube i went over to destiny's
stream trying to find one of the clips
and i almost got banned for
impersonating myself
this is like the funniest thing and
there was nothing i could do to convince
them
so i showed up and said hey can someone
point me to something
fake pacman and one of the moderators
said
i'm not going to let you stay in here
with that username
[Laughter]
i almost got banned for impersonating
myself and then i said
it's my personal account this is the one
i use to browse youtube how can i verify
um and i think i left quickly enough
that um i didn't uh i didn't get banned
but i almost got banned for
impersonating david pakman
can you imagine guys i mean if that that
is just absolutely something else
um okay thank you everybody joe biden
signed it
we answered questions we did it all
we really did it all and i'll be back
with everybody very soon
you